for the past 36 years the legend of
zelda has long been heralded as the
pinnacle of action adventure gaming and
for good reason i mean everybody wants
to play as a kid swinging a sword around
breaking your neighbor's pots right
jokes aside there are actually many
reasons why zelda games have captivated
audiences for several generations now
and one of the biggest reasons is the
characters these three recurring
characters make up the famous trio
that's even present on the official
zelda website and is set to make a
reappearance in the sequel to breath of
the wild but since we still don't even
know the name of the upcoming game and
the last time nintendo mentioned to the
series was on its nintendo of america
account back in march i figured we'd
look at the past instead of the future
of the franchise and instead focus on
how these beloved and highly
recognizable and marketable characters
came to be along the way if you find
yourself liking this video please
consider liking the video and if you
find yourself liking me please consider
subscribing chances are high that you'll
like my other stuff and you can always
unsubscribe later anyway to talk about
who or what inspired the zelda trio we
first have to talk about a brief history
of character art in video games when the
zelda trio first appeared in the world
of gaming the world was simpler the
technology at the time was such that
games looked like a bunch of squares
moving around on the screen i mean
technically they still are since
everything is just pixels anyway but on
the nes which was the system that the
legend of zelda released on in 1986 the
maximum resolution output was a whopping
256 horizontal pixels by 240 vertical
for reference this is what that looks
like compared to a modern full hd
resolution standard of 1920x1080 which
is what i rented this video in and
people used to say these games have
great graphics whoa nice graphic because
of these extremely constrictive
parameters for what can appear on screen
in a video game game developers at the
time had to try to design main
characters to be as recognizable as
possible and this is why miyamoto and
team came up with the idea of having
zelda's main character have a sword and
shield that's kind of super-sized and
indistinguishable from link's final
silhouette and just like they did with
mario by designing his hat and giant
nose to be recognizable they designed
link with a long hat and giant pointy
ears instead of a giant rounded nose and
when they were thinking about a
character with a pointed hat and ears
that loves adventure being huge disney
fans miyamoto and ko were immediately
reminded of the one and only peter pan
according to miyamoto himself they began
to take inspiration from peter pan and
that's actually why link's clothes are
green and since peter pan is a child
they also decided to make link a child
as opposed to his platforming
counterpart mario which actually worked
out very well because the entire idea
behind the legend of zelda stemmed from
memories of shigeru miyamoto's childhood
which he says consisted of many days of
whimsical exploration of the japanese
countryside in the 1950s he even
happened upon a massive cave system
which he eventually worked up the nerve
to explore all by himself with the light
of a lantern and found an undocumented
lake on the top of a hill which all
sounds really cool which is why he made
the legend of zelda he wanted to impart
that feeling from his younger days of
exploration and imagination to gamers
all over the world and thus the
character that would carry out this
adventure who was inspired by peter pan
visually would end up being the child
known as link oh and his name by the way
came from the notion that the original
zelda game would take place in both the
past and future so link would literally
be the link between the timelines i'm
not joking this is all from direct
quotes from interviews of miyamoto
moving on the same trope that was used
in the donkey kong super mario brothers
franchise of a damsel in distress which
the hero must save which by the way was
literally based off of the popeye
cartoon was also used in the legend of
zelda because let's face it we all want
to play as a hero who has to save
somebody when coming up with the idea
for who link would have to save though
it was actually a public relations agent
working for nintendo at the time that
suggested that the character of the
woman needing saving would be a lady of
eternal beauty kind of a legendary
concept in and of itself they wanted to
come up with a name that sounded like a
legendary beauty but instead of
fabricating one the same agent then
suggested that they use the unique name
of the wife of a famous american author
known as f scott fitzgerald she was a
woman who was known for her beauty and
being an author and dancer and her name
was zelda and thus princess zelda was
created her visual design doesn't have
any spectacular or specific details as
to why she ended up initially being a
redhead wearing a pink dress but we can
only assume that her coloration was
decided upon in order to contrast with
the green of link or the blue of ganon
and what a crafty segue into talking
about the creation of ganon see once
upon a time in austin texas a mommy
akita and a daddy akita loved each other
very much and ganon was created then i
drove down and paid a lot of money to oh
oh sorry wrong ganon the original ganon
from the legend of zelda was created
because the game needed a villain
obviously but instead of going the same
route that mario did with the king
kong-ish big monkey donkey kong just
kind of blindly wanting to steal a lady
away they felt that because zelda was
more of an adventure and had a bigger
concentration on good versus evil the
villain needed to be someone a bit more
sinister and you know evil his original
name when they were developing the
legend of zelda was actually hakai short
for cho hakai but where did that name
come from you ask great question they
wanted to stick with the idea of an
animalistic villain that worked out so
well for donkey kong so they actually
pulled inspiration from an older
fictional novel set in 7th century china
the book deals with ancient chinese
mythology and is called journey to the
west in english it was written by wu
cheung in 1592 as one of his four great
classical novels of chinese literature
the book itself was about the journey of
son wukong or better known as the monkey
king and one of the main characters in
the book is the deeply complicated
sometimes friend sometimes faux half man
half pig monster known as zhu baiji or
in japanese cho hakai aka ganon hakai in
the book has kind of a similar story to
lucifer from the bible he was once a
great general of heaven but had a bit
too much to drink one night and tried to
have his way with chonga the goddess of
the moon and was subsequently cast down
to earth by the jade emperor where he
was reborn from a pig well as a
man-eating pig monster i won't go into
all the details of a story because you
know there's a whole book about it but
in a nutshell hakai is a deeply
developed anthropomorphic pig monster
who ultimately cannot resist the wiles
of his physical temptations whether it
be for food or lust and is often used as
a villain in the story even going so far
as to get this kidnap the daughter of a
village elder and demand her hand in
marriage if that sounds familiar it's
because that's literally ganon who like
i said was named hakai before the game
was released a deeper more sinister
pig-like villain was perfect for the
battle of good versus evil that the
legend of zelda would handle and thus
ganon was designed as an anthropomorphic
pig monster who kidnapped princess zelda
out of his lust for power but the depth
of his character that stemmed from his
roots in his chinese mythological
character counterpart remained inside
the minds of the zelda developers even
though there wasn't much to begin with
in the original game and this is why
ganon was given an actual backstory in
the third zelda game a link to the past
when it was revealed via the game
booklet that he used to be a man with a
first and last name known as ganondorf
dragmire now at this point all three
characters were established in the first
game and in the games to follow they
made reappearances and were redesigned
based off of their old designs combined
with the new direction for the games in
zelda 2 a link to the past and link's
awakening so i won't go into specific
details on those games however things
got really interesting once again when
nintendo made the famous jump to 3d with
the nintendo 64. redesigning the mario
characters to now be featured in three
dimensions was easy because everyone's
designs were already so recognizable and
the target audience for the games was
everyone with a focus on children so
there was a need to keep everybody as
recognizable as possible but for the
legend of zelda's evolution in ocarina
of time the team had some other things
to consider see zelda was popular in
japan but it was super popular in other
parts of the world namely america where
we're a big fan of good versus evil
stories and their audience worldwide
that was a fan of the legend of zelda
for all those reasons were now 10 years
older because of this nintendo wanted to
focus a bit more heavily on really
nailing the theme of having cool and
more mature and better looking
characters than ever before which is why
they decided to design teenage heroes
instead of just children with the
ability to travel in between timelines
that they've always wanted to do at the
same time the wife of the man in charge
of the character designed for ocarina of
time a man named yoshiaki koizumi
explained to him that nintendo's
characters were all weird looking
no joke this inspired him to make
several changes to the cooler adult
link's face such as making his nose
narrower and stronger and cutting back
on his previously iconic long sideburns
and giving him pierced ears he also gave
him that long white visible underwear so
as to not make him too cool apparently
even though i personally think he looks
cooler with them but you know it's
whatever anyway he then entrusted the
fine details to an artist working under
him known as yusuke nakano who
reportedly designed link's face after a
quote world famous hollywood actor now
we've never gotten a confirmation as to
who exactly he was referring to but
without going into too much jargon
trying to explain why the chances are
highest given the timing of the 90s and
the age of link and the reference to
american actors that the actor who
inspired link's appearance in ocarina of
time was none other than leonardo
dicaprio the blonde teenaged 90s
heartthrob honestly i could see it now
princess zelda's jump to 3d was a bit
less drastic since they more or less
kept her initial royal getup with the
tiara and triforce earrings and tabard
laid over a dress from a link to the
past they tweaked several things though
like the colors by making her tabard
more of a purple than pink but added in
some new stuff like long gloves a
turtleneck and my favorite lore
implications by placing the sheikah
symbol beneath the triforce on her
tabard but other than that zelda pretty
much looked the same now gannon on the
other hand got perhaps the biggest
redesign of all of them by making his
anthropomorphic pig monster nest taller
and lankier and now wielding two swords
instead of a trident but the biggest
change was that you don't even see ganon
until the very end of the game in fact
you don't even hear his name ganon's
backstory from a link to the past was
expounded upon an ocarina of time by
bringing the character known as ganodorf
dragmire to life for the first time who
is the main villain that we follow
throughout the game ganondorf is
undoubtedly one of the coolest parts of
ocarina of time and again since the
developers at nintendo knew they needed
to design a character that was both
intriguing but also intimidating for
their growing teenage audience they
needed to think big literally and just
like link was designed based off of an
actor ganondorf was also designed based
off of another american actor known as
christopher lambert from highlander now
lambert might not be that big standing
at 5 foot 10 but he does have some
pretty big facial features which
reappeared on ganondorf's facial design
to start with the man has a hell of a
forehead which is the most obvious
detail that ganondorf also shares
although he normally covers that up with
a gerudo gemstone the lower stern brow
and sharp nose also made it over to
ganondorf's face and as such has
resulted in one of the most recognizable
and intimidating villains in video game
history and since ocarina of time the
zelda trio have gone through several
other redesigns but in each case it's
entirely related to the style of that
particular zelda game a super cartoony
bobble head and wind waker super darkly
edgy and twilight princess small town
storybook vibes and skyward sword and
finally a brand new blend of all of them
in breath of the wild as far as their
origins though you may now consider
yourself a bonafide expert unless you
already knew all of this either way
though let me know what you thought
about this video and if you learned
something new in the comments below and
also let me know if you'd like me to
cover any other topic of any other game
under the sun thank you so much for
watching and thank you in advance for
liking the video if you haven't already
and for subscribing if you haven't
already you totally should though huge
thanks as always to my bandit crew of
which i have the new name of damiana m
to announce that's all i've got in this
one so be sure to follow me on my
socials links are in the description
below i hope all of you have a wonderful
rest of your day this is bandit looking
forward to seeing you next time and
signing out
[Music]
you